y'all so we over here we had um a Muslim
Mosque and a popcorn Islam is a false
religion Muhammad was a false prophet
the hey guys so we're here on the
property I'm waiting for the for the
email assalamu alaikum greetings of
Peace welcome to the dean sham at your
host we got a lot to talk about have you
ever seen a cowboy except islamor we got
one here with us we're gonna hair they
are gone
here in Texas from a cowboy Muslim
um
[Music]
all right
I've known brother Eddie and they didn't
show for many many years and as a matter
of fact I was one of the original people
who showed up on his show alhamdulillah
and he's been doing a great job
alhamdulillah and spreading the dean of
Allah through his show through his
activities in andawa right now they work
in hamdullah on a great project the dean
Center which is now taken this dawa from
such a small show to become nice
larger audience and they need your
support and I give them my support to
shout out for the dean Center hopefully
inshallah you can look into it and put
some ironic charity and walk for
yourself to each other that brings you
continuous charity for the rest of your
life until the day of Judge support that
incentives
[Music]
and we're going to talk about his story
his journey and his interaction with a
Christian who came to visit the Muslims
at a mosque they come with the right
intentions the wrong intentions we'll
let you be the judge of that and we got
also another special guest here in the
dean show Studio
[Applause]
and his final messages
[Music]
mm-hmm
assalamu alaikum
how are you Brothers doing please
introduce yourself
all right uh yes my name is
co-founder and president of Islam by
touch the only organization in North
America dedicated to making Islam
accessible and available to the blind
community
and I am Brandon Estes not a direct
relationship Yusuf Estes and many of you
might know me as the Muslim cowboy and
so this is uh it's an honor to be here
Eddie I'm really mashallah happy to see
you again for the second time and it's a
pleasure to be here in the studio I had
a glove feet for having us yeah both of
you with us so uh when I opened up I
said uh Muslim Cowboy introduced
yourself with the Muslim Cowboy people
think of uh John Wayne
and Clint Eastwood and some of the Good
the Bad and the Ugly yeah and now we got
a Muslim couple can Cowboys be Muslim
you know that's actually uh I don't
wanna anyone to steal the idea but we're
going to be putting some T-shirts out
soon inshallah that says Cowboys can be
Muslim too okay so yeah because I mean
if a cowboy chooses to uh submit his
will to the creator of the heavens and
earth that's what a Muslim is That's
What Muslim is at so simple okay it
doesn't have to necessarily be from
Texas even though you are from Texas
right yeah Alabama Georgia wherever
Montana apparently yeah
so for people didn't that didn't get to
see our first program we talk about your
story they go there for more details can
you just give us kind of a summary a
breakdown we'll brought you to Islam you
come from a Christian background for
sure uh yes I was raised a Methodist and
then as time went on we became
non-denominational but I was raised in a
very traditional
um very loving Christian household my
parents you know loved you know the
church it was very important in our
lives and we had a lot of community
around us and But as time went on just
like most people who do find Islam and
other people who have issues with
Christianity you know I had a lot of
questions right I had a lot of questions
that just were not adequately answered
and couldn't be answered so I started
looking for those answers myself right
and to you know kind of sum this all
back up it all led up to 2010 where I
read through the Bible again after
having some
run-ins with Trouble In My Life we'll
just put it like that this time and I
was at a turning point where I had to
make some major decisions in my life and
so I was like okay I've got to change my
life in all these other ways let's look
at religion because that was always the
most important thing to me my
relationship with God was very important
I mean even since I was seven years old
we had Woods by our house and back then
when I was young we could be out from
seven in the morning to seven at night
but as long as you're home for dinner
you're fine your mom wouldn't worry
about you no cell phones no nothing and
so I used to go out in the woods and I
would just talk to God and just as a
little kid you know no instruction no
nothing it's just God was someone I just
talked to like Jesus or God to God the
Father I never talked to Jesus we would
always in prayer they teach you you got
to say in Jesus name we pray I mean but
I always questioning that why why in
Jesus name you know so
because you know I I don't know if
you're familiar with that is there
anywhere in the Bible that says to pray
in Jesus name is God or the other
prophets tell us to pray in Jesus name
there isn't yeah and so I always thought
that was interesting but you know that
one one verse in there that says look to
pray in Jesus name Jesus never said it
Divine or he's right
explicitly we're we're told I mean what
is the what's the what does Jesus tell
us to pray to what's the Lord's Prayer
yeah or father out in heaven Hallowed be
thy name he's praising the one up above
right absolutely and so that's what I
would do and so going back forward again
um what happened with me is once I read
through the Bible and read through a lot
of those ambiguous verses where it says
I and the father are one I was like okay
one in purpose you know now you mention
a key word ambiguous yes ambiguous
statements that are not explicit right
because you have explicit statements in
the Bible like in Hosea 11 9 where God
says that I will not come against the
cities of Ephraim again right I will not
basically I will not destroy them again
for I am the Lord your God I am not a
man very explicit God is saying in this
verse and what Hosea 11 9. so people can
look this up Hosea 11 9. because a lot
of people like to quote numbers 23 19
right where it says God is not a man
that he should lie nor the son of a man
that he should repent and they said well
Jesus didn't lie and he didn't have to
repent he never repented so therefore it
doesn't apply to him well that's still
an explicit verse but okay you don't
like that verse I'll use one that's even
more explicit God says in Hosea 11 9 I
am God is not a man period that's as
clear as this that's as good as it gets
I am not a man and so when I presented
those verses with the ambiguous verses
of whoever has seen me has seen the
father well this could mean a lot of
things it could mean that you know okay
you he's he there because the messengers
as we know in Islam they're sent with
the purpose of God a messenger if you
live in a kingdom let's take over the
Middle Ages and a king sends a messenger
to you and this messenger comes with the
letter if you reject that messenger are
you not rejecting the king yes
absolutely and the King will send his
soldiers after you reject the messenger
to come forcibly take you right and so
this this is what I saw all this to mean
all these ambiguous verses I realized
that okay they could be taken this way
so I
in 2010 became a Unitarian Christian not
the new age unitarians where everybody's
going to heaven type of thing but an
actual I believe that Jesus was a
messenger of God but I'm not going to
worship him again and this was without
meeting anymore that's what a Unitarian
Christian is right the original
unitarians like the followers of Arius
some of the old historians back in the
day they don't really exist anymore
there are people who are Unitarian there
have been some groups here and there
have come and they fizzled out and
you'll even find on online groups of
people who are trying to revive the idea
of Unitarianism meaning that the
non-deification of Jesus yeah many
historians saying back where my family's
from Bosnia that the Unitarian they were
Unitarian almost like Unitarian
Christians before they accepted Islam so
they didn't believe Jesus was God
literal Son of God and then when Islam
finally came they ended up it just fit
it makes sense yeah it's up to Islam and
my grandmother
um the only one in my family who
converted you know whenever I went to go
tell her about you know Islam a couple
years before she passed away the day
that she gave her shahada I asked her
these questions and she said Brandon I
never believed Jesus was God your
grandmother yeah she's like we always
believed and taught that Jesus was sent
by God you know and it's just like you
know so many people just fitrally right
their their inner condition that'll all
create them they understand this right
they just they you know she must have
read the the verse where he says I've
been sent by God right right so
um but you know back to my story just so
we can you know move on a little bit is
that after that for four years I didn't
know what to do with it I was just like
okay I'm a Unitarian Christian and so
but I would have to still go to church
and there's no Unitarian churches so I
have to go to trinitarian churches so I
watched The Passion of the Christ done
by Mel Gibson which he is a trinitarian
but he did the whole movie in Aramaic no
Gibson he's a trinitarian yeah very
strong Catholic very strong Catholic so
he uh he did the whole movie in Aramaic
and what's the name for God in Aramaic
it's
right and after watching the movie I
realized okay the the name that he used
in the entire movie that you know
Aramaic speaking Christians which this
is what language Jesus spoke is right
and so in church because I was a
Unitarian I didn't want to say in Jesus
name anymore so whenever they would
raise their hands and say in Jesus name
under my breath I would say in Allah's
name I pray I'm in and I did this for
four years and it wasn't until the
pastor one day
uh he had made this statement and we
didn't have any Muslims in our community
like I had met a Muslim until after I
converted right I knew a Palestinian who
who had became a Muslim but you know we
weren't really in touch anymore he did
help me get to the mosque but like there
was just no Muslims around us and the
pastor randomly said guys do not be like
the Muslims I don't want to hear about a
single one of you putting your head on
the ground he said we get on our knees
and put our hands up like this and pray
we don't humiliate ourselves like the
Muslims and put our our faces in the
dirt and
I was like this is weird like one why
are you even talking about Muslims we
don't have any Muslims around us you
know I wasn't an anti-muslim at this
point I was just I was neutral and I was
like this is just really strange
so a couple weeks later whenever I you
know am having this really bad day and
you know completely sober but just
really sad I opened up my Bible to you
know Matthew where Jesus is basically
before he's about to get allegedly taken
by the Romans and he says oh don't you
know don't take this cup from me he
didn't want to go to the Cross right if
this was his mission he did he didn't
want to go he's asking God to not take
him to the Cross but what did he do he
fell on his face and I remembered right
that Randy why did he say this two weeks
ago and it's humiliating I get being
humble you know we wouldn't but he's
telling us don't do this and I said I
follow Jesus and I don't worship him but
he's my role model
and so I had this moment where I'm like
I've got to uh I'm gonna do what Jesus
did not what Randy's telling me to do
and when I did it
I asked for guidance and you know
everything just became clear wow this is
an important point right there what you
were saying that when you start praying
to the you never prayed to Jesus and
Jesus Calling upon Allah basically and
Aramaic and because a lot of times
people get stuck on the word Allah and
translate it was me Doug how would you
translate God
and what's awesome about the gelata the
name of Allah in Arabic it can't be
pluralized yeah it was one of the only
words in Arabic that cannot it can't be
made Gemma which is pluralized so it's
so uniquely one in every essence argue
this I like to stick on this just for a
minute because it's so important it's
it's like a aha moment for some people
to be like wow this is like I didn't
think about this because those you've
heard the thing that the moon God I I
don't know what kind of um ignorant
person would still bring that up but
when you bring these points to light
Jesus didn't speak English she spoke
Aramaic and he said Allah Allah he
called he said Allah you can look it up
and Jews and Christians who are arabic
speaking in the Bible they use Allah
correct absolutely so where are you
going with that
that a lot of people have followers that
don't know any better unfortunately and
they they play on the ignorance of their
own followers knowing or thinking that
their followers aren't going to check
back up but what happens is when they
have the followers who actually
accidentally you know think okay maybe
I'll go look something up what happens
they thought oh my pastor lied to me or
they say something that like Randy said
and it's like you know kind of strange
and then they find out well Jesus did
this you know so what happens is they're
they're going to end up pushing the
people away and which is good right
because we want people to see the light
to see that this is the same message
since Adam Abraham you know all of the
prophets worship the one God the Creator
not the creation and then uh what is it
Matthew 26 39 you mentioned pastors
saying don't fall on your face and pray
don't do it don't humiliate yourself the
book is saying the book The Bible is
saying that he did fall on his face is
it 26 39 and he went a little further
and he fell on his shoes a little
further and fell on his face and who
else falls on the face to pray Muslims
Muslims that's it wow this is the mother
so you're you're um and then you went on
to uh study and you went so deep that
you had to study to the heart of Islam
to Medina right yeah the city now you're
speaking the Arabic language yeah uh
yeah I'm attempting I got a lot of I
feel like it's a lifelong journey still
you know for someone too like me from
where I come from I just like someone
now who if they're trying to study an
original language to really get closer
to what Jesus spoke Aramaic it's like
almost like impossible I'm not like who
does that now yeah right the original
language you don't find people who do
people are going by this is with all due
respect we're just bringing certain
things to light if someone most people I
would say 99.9 percent
don't know the group what is it in Greek
the Kone who speaks yeah very very few
people so right now someone can go ahead
like uh we'll get into it as um you had
this person it doesn't seem like he had
good intentions will the people judge
and if he says something he got some
ignorant Muslim who doesn't really know
much may God forgive him forgive us and
if we're and he's he's talking about the
Quran and whatnot you knowing the air
but you can go back and say no no that's
English translate this actually the mean
the word means this
because you can look at the original one
that's deep that's really important too
yeah I mean even people who aren't going
to be Scholars I think it's something
that's
imperative for for Muslims like
especially if you're parents right and
you you're raising kids to at least have
a basic understanding of like the key
verses at least and the Arabic meaning
so that when people try to twist and
take things out of context you can go to
it and say no I can read this and this
says actually this it doesn't it doesn't
say what you're saying it says yeah
right well back to this word before we
go on another So you you're you um flew
in Arabic right your parents are from
where from Palestinian Palestinian right
yes tell us about that now is it true
have you met some Palestinian Christians
oh yeah yes what do they use for God the
name they say Allah they say Allah just
like we say in the word Allah
Palestinian Christians Palestinians
Christians yes yeah yeah actually uh
subhanallah just maybe just a couple
months ago I had uh dinner with the
Palestinian Christian yeah who I met and
we actually I was literally asking him
questions you know like how does this
work you know because I I never I never
interacted before you know and
alhamdulillah uh even though I was born
and raised in an Arab household right uh
it took work to really see because you
know uh us being Arabs native Arab
speakers we have our own dialects right
yeah it's not similar to uh to the words
of the of the Quran you know to that
Arabic of the Quran so you know it took
some time when I growing up for me to
actually sit there and learn and
understand you know these ayat and it's
very important it's very important
especially as as uh
as Brandon over here said you know it's
very important to understand the key
ayat the core of your Deen right because
you will have tricksters like this try
to come up to you and psych you out
so then um both of you now you're also I
mean you got so passionate went to
Medina because you see all the
misconceptions the stereotypes so was
that what motivated you you're like okay
I want to learn more so I can be well
equipped so I can educate
my fellow Americans here on really what
Islam is about and you also taking it
yourself to educate uh because you're
legally blind yes okay so now you're
making material in what's the script
called uh we use uh we use braille
Braille large print uh digital formats
we try to to make Islam available for
blind people in any way they can access
it yeah but both of you now so
passionate that you're in your in your
area you're also here former Christian
American Cowboy Texas
you're now back here in America and
you're letting people know that this is
indeed a way to life to consider at
least consider it check it out and the
people are waking up I mean Eddie you
know and I want to thank you first you
know before before you go chop off any
because people are into all sorts of
stuff call your hair blue red chop over
body healthy body parts yeah all sorts
of stuff so consider what try you know
you know the thing is before you make a
decision that you were going to regret
yeah and and and the thing is is you
know they're trying it's so clear that
there's certain narratives that are
being trying they're trying that they're
really trying hard to shove down your
throat so many of these ideas you know
uh but we have so there's so many people
that live in logic in common sense
so whenever they see how Islam lines up
with that common sense and that logic
alhamdulillah you know the they're drawn
to it they're drawn to alhamdulillah did
your family when you accepted Islam were
they program also like these are the
Sharia people these are like the enemies
like you see a lot of uh I just did a
response to One Pastor and he was like
and how would you respond to this when
um
The Host this guy Patrick asked this um
he's a preacher I don't know if you've
heard of um
I think it's Charlie Kirk
I've heard of Charlie Kirk yeah you have
yeah and they're going in a good
direction they're trying to bring
Muslims together to go ahead and
unite against all the sexualization of
the children really good move that's
really nice but then when he was asked
why is there this like animosity between
you know he gave an impression that
Christians they feel like like we have
an animosity towards them
and they have an animosity towards us
why because they want to bring the
radical Muslims they want to bring
Sharia here and whatnot so we said
Sharia is already here it's here you
know charity is here prayer is here all
that we and we list everything and then
as far as I mean
unless you're coming from over here
throwing drones and whatnot you expect
people to be happy about you know
occupying right but otherwise how would
you respond to that no that's a that's a
very good point I'm I'm really big and
when when responding and talking to
people flipping the script and actually
not letting them keep us on the back
foot and you made that point right there
when you were saying sharia's already
here right don't say oh but this but
that you know I I think Muslims need to
get away from this idea of like
immediately feeling like they have to
defend them apologetic or apologizing
yeah we need to immediately be able to
one understand what they're saying and
understand where they're coming from
that but that takes asking questions and
a lot of people just like to respond so
we also need to ask questions challenge
them right back right and and and and
make these kind of responses of yeah is
already here and then then explain well
what what is Sharia it's being kind to
your parents you know making sure that
you are fulfilling the rights of your
neighbors they're our neighbors we're
living next to them am I making sure
that they're getting the rights because
I'm going to be asked about the rights
of my neighbors on the day of judgment
so they need once you can do that and do
it in a way that captivates them
then you can then you have their heart
because this this Dean and the
propagation of it it's a balance
connecting Hearts it's not about just
throwing information and pamphlets here
and we do the pamphlets because that's
part of what we do because we need to
spread this but the most important thing
is to be able to show honor and dignity
without being aggressive and also not
being you know weak right because a
Muslim is someone who stands upright but
we're still humble right we're not
arrogant but we hold ourselves and we
have a composure that people when they
see us they know that they're not going
to they they're not going to they're
gonna think twice about beating up our
wives our women they're going to think
twice about harming us and they'll also
understand that they're safe from us
their wealth their blood their their
physicality they are going to be safe
from us
and uh when you say Sharia Ten
Commandments the the what Moses was
given absolutely that's all Sharia I
mean even I mean there's people think
the Ten Commandments are the only
Commandments Moses was given he was
given over 600 Commandments correct in
the in the Bible itself but you know all
of these things that what it means to to
to not do any of these major bad actions
the Sharia is something that is a way
to the linguistic Point like Sharia
comes from
which is like a path a road a Tariq and
some Scholars have said that it's a path
that leads you to cold water so on and
so forth so the Sharia is something that
will lead you to goodness right it leads
you away from that which is harmful and
Lead You towards that which will benefit
you Divine Law exactly this is and
what's better
God's law or man's law perfect law or
imperfect changing law that constantly
does it make sense sometimes one day
it's this way another day it's that way
making stuff up as you go isn't shitty
also I mean it's in the Bible absolutely
Moses what he was given all the prophets
who came with laws that is Sharia they
had a different name because they spoke
different languages just an Arabic term
for the same thing that the Moses was
given with the the original Torah that
he was actually getting yeah it's like
uh someone you know can be twisted and
be like man these guys trying to bring
Salam any like all worried about salaam
and they'd be like what is Salam he's
peace oh salaam and then once you
educate them oh okay it's not that bad
it's not that bad it's not what I
thought it was it's just they have this
propaganda in their ear constantly so
they associate these words with negative
connotations and that's from the uh hate
the islamophobia industry it's a machine
that now is a multi it's a billion
dollar industry I mean it's huge with
the networks and everything I think it
was a 300 million but we added now with
all the the networks and the TV and
everything plus the billion dollar
industry I mean people people and plus
all the individuals who are now going on
making accounts to profit and get their
own big businesses it's very big
business I mean even even uh even their
propagation you know subhanallah like
we're talking about you know this
accessible material for blind people uh
you know let me let me give you a quick
statistic right there's about eight to
nine million Jehovah's Witnesses in the
world right not very many eight to nine
million Jehovah's Witnesses in the world
yet they spend over a million dollars a
year just on making their material their
dowel material their down material
accessible for blind people
think about that like they aren't just
attacking but they're actively uh
proselytizing
so you know we really gotta step up our
game on in every Avenue here yeah and I
think if we can uh just go ahead and
present what we have now we have to go
ahead and uh we welcome people to come
we love when when the people come to
visit us at the Massachusetts we have
open houses but we had this one
individual that you actually responded
to and we can go ahead and maybe learn
some lessons from this and I think uh
congregations like this who have people
like this who are pushing you know this
false information and this hate and
whatnot I mean uh they don't deserve the
backing unless he changes his ways from
from so when people hopefully see this
people who are his congregants and want
to be like I don't want to be with this
this guy who's you know spreading these
kind of lies and misinformation
absolutely so um let's get into um some
of the things that you got you actually
responded to and I think this is the and
we enjoy if somebody has some questions
if they're sincere and they respectfully
ask no problem absolutely we love we
love to love the diner we love the
questions yeah
all right let's get right into
um this this is a pastor or a preacher
he's he considers himself basically a a
missionary like on the ground apologist
for Islam for Christianity okay let's go
okay also we over here we had um a
Muslim mosque in Apopka in the city
where our church is at so that's by his
uh close to his church yeah it's a yeah
it's there in Florida packed by the
grace of God I've learned on
apologetics when it comes it comes to
Islam
Islam is a false religion Muhammad was a
false prophet at the the okay let's go
from there so he mentioned uh quite a
few things here uh Islam's false
religion false prophet
and promotes
some uh what else he said promotes war
and uh you know bad things like I don't
know if you can I bleeped it out because
I didn't want YouTube to you know give
me any strikes or anything but yeah he
mentioned these these things that he
says that Islam promotes right yeah so
right off the bat I mean he's not uh he
doesn't seem like he's
he's going in a direction that we can
sit and you know uh he's insulting right
off the bat there's no good intention in
his uh in his behavior at least based
off of what we have so far come come sit
with us talk with us absolutely that's
the whole thing that we can sit and die
along top but you don't come sit at a
man's table or come to Matt's house you
can insulting him right off exactly yeah
salt and his mother his father for sure
uh so how would you answer that though
well there's maybe someone uh is
thinking it but they not as you know uh
ignorant as as you know some person
people can be but uh it would be one
thing if he was an atheist or maybe an
ex-muslim but he's a Christian who he's
a trinitarian Christian who he believed
Jesus is the father Jesus is the holy
all of these are all one entity right
and so then by that same notion he
recognizes that everything in in the
Bible is from God according to him
Deuteronomy 20 right 15 through 18 God
commanded Moses to go into the city and
kill everything alive they breathes and
he's talking about murder and you know
uh rape go to number 16 right where uh
the they're commanded to go into the
cities and to kill the infants to kill
the donkeys to to I mean War he says War
mom is all about war well you know his
God Jesus was about war even to the
extent to where you're commanded to to
take care of babies right as in like you
know take everything alliteration
absolute obliteration and except for the
young girls who are prepubescent then
you save them for yourselves and what do
the the Jewish mufacturing the Jewish
execute say of that you know we we'll
leave it at that right so you know
everything that if he wants to say this
is in Islam which we don't believe that
we don't say that Islam is about murder
you know it's not about that it's about
Justice it's about stopping corruption
and and you know preserving life you
know anything that is registered in
Islam when it comes to these things when
it is altercations right there are
things we have rules we have laws but
when he he doesn't even look at his own
book where there are things that it's
almost like lawlessness right and
there's a lot of things that you you
can't it's like the pot calling the
kettle black but it's not even that
because he's just coming with statements
exactly like he's not backing it up with
anything you know I could come in here
and say Hey you know the sky is orange
you know what I mean and then walk away
that's pretty much what he's doing just
throwing up words putting out claims
with nothing to back it up same way you
hear a lot of people repeat repeat this
uh Muslims are violent because of
prophet Muhammad War peace and blessed
be upon him uh but I like this example
now if you're a Christian you look at
some of the biblical prophets and you
get a great example of Moses uh how many
people was it 3 000 in Exodus when he
came down they're worshiping the calf
and then in one shot three thousand were
just taken out immediately right yeah
absolutely and I think that's that's
double the amount what is it when I've
interviewed different Scholars and
students of knowledge and
um when they calculate all the people
who were on both sides during all the
battles over the entire prophethood of
the Prophet Muhammad it was actually
just a little over a thousand so it's
three times as much three times okay I
mean people gotta like remember this so
total number of people from both sides a
thousand people yeah and that's in one
that's not going in it's completely
obliterating this is combat this is
combat this is them protecting this is
the Muslims protecting their city of
Medina from infiltration of people the
entire Arabian Peninsula coming against
them these are not people in places of
worship and monasteries non-combatants
because not women not children there's
Rules of Engagement that that Muslims
have to abide by whenever in times of
battle like that yeah because you can't
go ahead and kill not and come back you
can't kill them animals you can't uh you
know take down the foliage you can't
chop down trees you can't you know
there's rules most I mean you you're you
hear this uh often uh repeated because
Muslims know this this is basic but you
don't you don't know this no he doesn't
but he's trained in apologies
he studied his trained from the school
of ignorance
and how many people actually died from
The Sword of prophet Muhammad was it uh
I believe if I'm not mistaken one it was
one it was one it was one by his hand
that we have authentically know of yeah
authentically authentically no correct I
mean that's a great difference when and
I always I just make this example from
people praising uh some of what are some
of the people that come to mind as
Alexander the Great and who are some of
these people that have known him through
history and people have kind of Praise
them as like you know great conquerors
and whatnot yeah I mean even the the
military generals that they Praise of
World War One World War II yeah who have
killed many people yeah right just they
just they just made a movie about uh
Oppenheimer who made the atomic bomb
raising him yeah you know showing him in
this light you know showing kind of
showing him he's a human he's like a
human you know look at the human
component when they drop two atomic
bombs and hundreds hundreds of thousands
immediately that's not the ones that
we're afterwards that's how many people
died immediately that's a lot of
hypocrisy yeah very much what were the
context of these battles
well for the prophet Muhammad yes um
well first of all I mean they were they
were exiled from their City they were
all of their belongings were stolen from
them they were not allowed to migrate
with their things I mean they were
robbed and then kicked out and not only
that three years prior to them getting
kicked out they were starved and
boycotted where they were so hungry that
they would eat the leaves of trees and
one of the sahabi said he said I
remember a time where I was so hungry I
stepped on something Squishy in the
middle of the night and to this day I
don't know what it is
well what what about the Caravan they
bring this up uh they were looting
taking robbing the Caravan how do you
like to answer that well I mean you know
at the end of the day this Caravan which
was the the Battle of Good and Evil that
led to the Battle of weather right it
was full of the Muslims belongings it
was all their stuff it was all their
stuff that they were going to take to go
sell because you just said that if
somebody stopped and they pull it they
took their stuff so now they're taking
their stuff if somebody robbed your home
and then you found the guy that robbed
your home and took your stuff back are
you the bad guy that's the question
right right so this is this is why
education on our partners you know
getting knowledge having all the facts
is so important you know because you can
say the statement I like to tell people
if you just say a word just one word
kill okay you first your mind thinks you
might think of something we don't know
what you think of something this person
thinks then I'll say Joe killed okay
that also now means something okay that
could be a lot of things he could be but
most people think he's a bad guy then I
say Joe killed John and then okay you're
thinking okay Joe kill John Joe's
probably a bad guy but then I say Joe
killed John who was
uh attempting to Armed rob you know A
Lady Joe was a cop John had already
fired shots back and you get the whole
story now the whole thing completely
changes but this is what these
missionaries do they just say the few
words Muhammad killed
he fought he did war and they leave it
at that and when you don't have the rest
of the context and also when you don't
have the understanding and the the
What's called the certainty that he is a
prophet of God which we can prove right
we have all of the proofs of prophethood
and you understand that you know he was
sent by God he was one of the greatest
people
right he is the greatest example for
mankind and you understand that all of
this stuff fits within this context of
what was happening how they were treated
then it makes sense right but a lot of
people are are lazy and that's why we as
daddies have to really you know we work
hard you yourself and you know another
and all the guys are out there we have
we work hard to spread the correct
information to tell them the full story
and once people actually hear it those
who are sincere they're they're shocked
like I was when I first started finding
out this stuff about Islam yeah you know
I was like I was like kind of like not
you know that righteous anger like how
how could they have hid this from me for
so long that I've been lied to right
so now when you hear this in context
why there were battles then you go to
the beginning how they're persecuted
they didn't lift the finger driven out
and then they were given permission to
fight and this isn't self-defense right
no not killing uh innocent
non-combatants or children or women or
people in place of worship then it's
like okay this makes sense yeah
absolutely Geneva Convention all that
stuff before you had uh these these
rules of engagement laid out okay moving
along hey guys so we're here on the
property I'm waiting for the for the
email he's gonna come out here and talk
to me that's the leader they try to get
me confused
we're just doing like interviews to
spread positivity and that Jesus was
born of a virgin
yes it was born a virgin but he is not
God so he was but he was born of a
virgin so that so how was he born then
was Muhammad born of a virgin nope
person like you and I wow this was not
one who walked on water it was no
Miracles per se that he did other than
he received the message so uh this is a
important Point here you have the Muslim
uh he's speaking but he actually is
making some very incorrect statements
now about the Miracles of uh that he's
pretty much saying that Prophet Muhammad
saw some he didn't do any Miracles yeah
and this is uh categorically incorrect
totally 100 right that when you just
look at that I mean we have the miracle
The Living Earth of the of the Quran and
we don't flaunt both about man there are
so many miracles that he did himself
that's in the the Syrah in the history
yeah it's amazing you know there's over
over 100 authentically narrated miracles
from the prophet and when we take when
when you say uh break that down
unpackaged that when you say
authentically narrated that's like
there's a chain that connects and then
there's like uh Hadith what does that
mean how many people are witnessing
these things yeah I mean this these are
when it comes to the science of Hadith
which is the science of the narrations
that come from the prophet peace be upon
Him things that he said and he did I
mean we have one of the most exact
Sciences out of any science in the world
for authenticating events that happen
right we have different parts of it
right that it comes down to you know uh
you know which is the knowledge of men
right we have books that are filled with
the names of hundreds of thousands of
narrators were they were they
trustworthy were they reliable did they
forget things was this person unknown
and you know all of our Sunnah which is
the the life and the sayings of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him his
tacit approval it's all been preserved
just like the Quran has been preserved
so we know what things that are
preserved to us I mean what things are
have reached us are preserved and it
goes to a chain of narration that this
person you know learned from this person
who learned from this person who learned
from the companion of the Prophet
Muhammad peace upon who learned from the
prophet and we know each one of them we
know their biographies we know if they
were honest if they were truth
trustworthy and truthful so that way we
can say that Beyond any shadow of the
doubt that this is something that's
authentic and that's what it means when
we talk about authentic Hadith and if
there's even one person in the chain now
that we have a narration from who was
even forget he just he was forgetful
then it becomes a little bit weaker or
if someone was known to be a liar then
we won't even accept it or if one person
was unknown they they narrated from this
guy who narrowed from this unknown guy
we don't really know who he was he
wasn't known in his community it's
automatically rejected because we we're
not going to take something from someone
who's unknown right so the idea of
trustworthiness amongst the Arabs right
is something that was so huge even the
the poly who the problem was fighting
against they they put trust and honesty
on such a high level even though they
were fighting against him and didn't
want to accept him you know they knew
that he was the most truthful and
trustworthy person and it was one of the
greatest
no no is in that Arab civilization to be
a liar I mean they would fight over all
kinds of things but they're not going to
fight over people being Liars or this
and that there was an example what was
it Abu sufyan when he was in front of
the Christian King correct and he was uh
asking him about Prophet Muhammad and he
said look I would have lied he was like
praising him how did that go that story
yeah no so Abu sufyan who was uh after
the battle of brother he became the de
facto basically the main person of the
shura which is the consultation group of
the chief of the praise right the people
in Mecca and he met with the Emperor of
Constantinople right the Byzantine
Empire and when he was in front of him
he asked them certain questions about
the prophet Muhammad to kind of
determine if he was the prophet and in
that the whole time he asked him so many
questions and he obviously he wanted to
you know because he's against him he's
fighting against him he doesn't want
this this Emperor who he's trying to
seek his audience to help fight against
the prophet mama he doesn't want him to
you know start liking him and he even
said that like I would have lied you
know if I could have but I knew my
companion was right behind me and he
would have called me out if I had lied
this is somebody on his side like they
they had such a high value for honesty
and trustworthiness that you know I'm
following you yeah we're both they're
both they're both polytheist but if this
guy sees this guy as a liar he's not
gonna follow him anymore right so this
is something that we have to understand
that our tradition is is very preserved
and it's it's even it's even past like
right now we have so many historical
narratives that are just accepted point
blank no questions asked that are
nowhere near to the level of scrutiny
that we do and when it comes to Hadith
what was the um Emperor's name was the
heraculous miraculous yeah what didn't
he say at the end he said after hearing
he's he mentioned things like what was
his father King or was uh he was
mentioning certain things to see like
what's his motive like why is he
claiming he's a prophet once he heard
all this stuff he said something I'll go
I'd go wash his feet yeah I would go
wash his feet and verily his mission
like he he'll end up taking over the
land that is right here where we are
that's what he said about Prophet
Muhammad actually after he deciphered
through the questions that he asked he
knew that he was a prophet yeah he
accepted it he accepted that he was a
problem he didn't never he never became
a Muslim yeah but because he did Surah
he did consultation with his priests and
leaders and told them he told them about
this according to the narration that we
have and he said what do you think about
this and they said absolutely you better
not because he was telling them I think
we should you know let's let's follow
this man and they said no they're not
going to do this and he said okay yeah I
was just kidding yeah wow I'm not being
serious he might lose his position now
yeah yeah they overthrow him put someone
else in and so this is how people this
is how a law tests people right and you
know we see a lot that you know the
people who are in high positions of
authority they don't want to lose that
Authority right so yeah so going back to
uh Miracles uh there are over you said
100 of them over 100 authentically
narrated in America what are some that
come to mind you got the feeding of
almost a thousand no almost a thousand
soldiers during the Battle of hamdak
which is the trench right where they had
one pot of food that they the prophet
Muhammad instructed
um the right the wife of jabber Abdullah
in Haram to not take off the lid just
let me scoop it keep it covered until
everyone's been fed and they fed almost
a thousand people and when she after the
end of it she opened it up to see how
much food was left and it was still full
now these are people that are around
witnessing this correct and you have
this chain that goes back like you
described that they're the witnesses we
can see who we know their names right uh
what about the the water from his
fingers dressing forth from the finger
tips of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him that's wow this is profound
his cousin he actually had
um became blind one there before one of
the battles uh when they went to Khyber
right and like he couldn't see and it
was actually a really serious issue the
prophet peace be upon him you know wet
his fingers with his mouth and then he
wiped the eyes of Ali and his sight
returned
I mean again we have the living Miracle
the Quran you have prophecies in it you
have so many different signs in there uh
the authenticity of the Quran et cetera
Etc then now we're most Muslims don't
even talk about this right of course the
splitting of the Moon okay that's
splitting splitting of the moon this is
more authentically people they hear
about other people and
um some of their
uh some of the history that's narrated
and you said so properly that we don't
we how are you going to verify a lot of
this stuff absolutely but you had you
had the enemies of Islam who actually
narrate not we have Muslims but the
enemies of Islam at that time who said
they saw the moon coming apart and back
right yes and other people in different
continents who came and said there it's
also now I talked to sheikhail the man
about this and we talked about this and
he gave you know a really academic
approach to it and it's amazing wow it's
amazing it's amazing so we got that uh
prophecies he said false prophecies
I mean a false prophecy is a prophecy so
you have three different types of
Prophecy a prophecy that has been made
and hasn't come true so it doesn't mean
it's necessarily a false prophecy or
true prophecy it just hasn't come true
yet
then you have a true prophecy a prophecy
that was made and came true and then you
have a false prophecy a prophecy that
was made and that the time period that
it was given or something that happened
has passed the events for it's happening
has passed and therefore you can say it
is now a false prophecy
and so there's no false prophecies in
Islam there are prophecies that haven't
happened yet like the sun rising from
the West okay just because it hasn't
happened doesn't mean it but there are
plenty to have happened for example I'll
name a few and you could take it away
from here the building now during the
desert and the prophet saws predicting
is this a prophecy that's a prediction
that now the Arabs Bedouins Barefoot
they're going to be competing for the
tallest buildings competing in the
construction of the tallest buildings
and we're the tallest buildings now all
in the Middle East how is that a
coincidence or what
they would say that
okay when the prophet saw someone they
sent the Bounty Hunter after him and I
think it was his uh Malik yes so he's
with Abu Bakr siddiq right yeah and it's
amazing the the Bounty Hunters coming
after them and what happens he keeps
sinking in the sand horses feet keep
sinking in the sand and then what four
times and the he and every time he kept
saying you know I'm gonna stop you know
I'm gonna stop because he's noticing
something's worth happening and he's
pretty close so they can hear him and he
can hear them and and then after his
horse gets out of the stand he thinks
again about the 100 camel reward and
then he chases them again it happens
because that was the Bounty yes that was
the Bounty hundred camels if you catch
them and and by the way like one camel
equip these the camels that they would
have given are equivalent to like a
really nice Mercedes that's one camel so
think about 100 Mercedes I mean you're
gonna be you're gonna be really rich and
um the fourth time after after it
happened
you know he he knew something was
different and so he asked the prophet
for peace he asked him for peace he said
look I know that you know like I'm I'm
not going to come after you anymore but
once you're you know if you become
Victorious I want peace you know I don't
want I want a peace treaty agreement
from you that your followers are not
going to come after me right because he
went you know he was going to go on his
way and the prophet didn't just give him
this peace and blessings be upon him
he's on he's on the Hijra and I'm
getting Goosebumps right now but he's
he's making migration secretly running
away from the people who are trying to
assassinate him right in the middle of
the night him and his best friend Abu
Bakr Allah be pleased with him
he could have just said yeah we give you
a peace treaty but he went a step
further and just said let me tell you
something else he said you know kosaros
right who was the Emperor of one of the
two World superpowers at the time he
said you're going to wear his bracelets
nobody not even the family of kisura
will wear his bracelets it is the sign
of the emperor so think about this they
are two men in the middle of the desert
running for their lives right because
this all of the quraish are coming after
them
and he doesn't just say okay you know
we're going to give you a piece once if
we become strong and later he actually
tells him no I'm telling you that one
day you Soraka who is a pagan at this
time right you're going to wear the
bracelets of kiseral
and what do we find during the lifetime
of um
once they had defeated the Muslims this
small group of Believers had liberated
right because that's what it was it was
a liberation of the oppressive regime of
the Persians once they liberated the
people from that oppressive regime
and kissura had fallen and they had all
of their family infighting and fell in
on themselves what happened
Matic can become a Muslim and he was in
the Masjid and Omar had the two
bracelets of kisra and he put him on his
wrist wow
that is deep that's deep and this is
this is a prophecy fulfilled uh it's
like saying uh you're going to whatever
example we can give it's like let's say
um you're going to conquer Russia and
you're going to be wearing the these uh
embroidered Rolex from Putin yeah so
what people would if someone heard that
you think you're gonna pray you know
conquer uh uh the White House and where
if Trump was in office his orange wig
just an example that you can get so
you're covering the Titans Walker
Biden's Walker okay you're gonna conquer
him so this is just uh so people can
kind of get a better idea not making fun
of anybody but just so you can kind of
it can hit home you're gonna conquer
Persian you're gonna wear these special
bracelets that the the emperor at that
time or what is it called the kisser
like the ruler yeah the ruler he's
wearing these yes they're like God Kings
they're they're level this is deep okay
couple more
uh the Persian and Romans Persians the
Romans were defeated right yeah it's in
the Quran it's a prophecy right and then
Allah got Almighty saying in the Quran
that they're going to come back and
they're going to be victorious in a
period between three to nine years they
will be defeated okay what can you give
an example this is like a country that's
been you know superpowered that just
went under and now the prediction is
they're going to come back yeah they
were not even just that but think about
their entire economy had it collapsed
yeah right they historians say that
they're they were so completely ruined
right that you know people were there
was starvation there was all kinds of
problems that were happening within
their society and and it you know
non-muslim non-religious historians say
that it was a quote-unquote miracle that
they ever you know that they came back
right because what happened was they
ended up being Victorious yes right and
it was exactly within that time period
that the prophet Muhammad had given
right but what was happening was is that
he said between two and nine years and
so the time kept coming closer and
closer to the end of it and so the
polytheists were like oh you know this
prophecy that you know your your Prophet
Muhammad peace they said he made this
prophecy oh uh looks like the time
period's almost up you know you're gonna
looks like it hasn't happened
Allah said something also really
interesting in those same set of verses
he said on that day the Believers will
rejoice
and so you know some people say they're
going to Rejoice for the Romans winning
because but you know either way these
are both you know non-muslim armies of
fighting but the day that the news came
in
and that time period when this they got
the news was after the battle of Badr
so the Believers were rejoicing because
they had defeated 300 versus a group of
one thousand more armed more heavily on
men and then also on that top of that
defeat the news comes from akara Singh
the Romans have won so not only did the
Muslims defeat them in the Battle of
Badr where they had all their belongings
stolen that they got their belongings
back but they also got the Fulfillment
of the prophecy or the prophet saws said
that the Romans will be victorious right
it's actually a triple because there's
one more thing because if we go back
through the actual verses it says when
they were first defeated right which was
in the Battle of Antioch
um
and the the battle happened in the Dead
Sea Basin okay which is a basin right
there next to the Dead Sea in the Dead
Sea area up in in sham the Palestine
area
and it says they were defeated in the
lowest land
right at the neck Can it can mean two
things it can be in Arabic it means the
nearest or the lowest so it also is the
nearest because it's the nearest to the
Arabian Peninsula right out of all the
places that was the nearest land outside
of that area it also means edina's
islamp deals for Lois because this world
we call it called it Dunya right Dunya
means low right lowly Edina means lowest
like it means like Lois like when we say
in English big big or biggest small
smaller smallest it's the lowest lowest
so the triple
you know miracle in this is that there
was no such thing as subsea level uh
calculations and no one knew this kind
of stuff back then but within this last
century we found out you know how to
measure elevations and all this stuff
and the exact spot where the battle took
place where the Romans lost the first
battle you know when they first lost
in that Dead Sea Basin is the lowest
level on Earth subsea level wise
so all this came true and all this came
true this is amazing subhanallah Miracle
after Miracle after miracle yep What
miracles did he perform
um I can't verbatim him safely he healed
people
he did heal people
dead and all that and the the only
difference in what we believe Jesus and
Christianity is is that he's not God we
don't believe in the truth otherwise he
was a prophet he came with a message
he's the only Prophet that did Miracles
like that right out of all the prophets
he is all right so we cleared that up
this is totally false we just uh went
over some of the Miracles and for any
Muslim tomorrow what would you advise
the Muslim who's going to go ahead and
try to fulfill this obligation of
sharing answering questions dawah if you
don't know
to get the knowledge if you don't know
don't if you don't know say I don't know
yeah at least start with that because
saying I don't know in Islam we believe
it's half of knowledge to say I don't
know right even the great Imam Matic who
was one of the four Great Scholars right
of the early Traditions right of our our
jurisprudence he was asked many times
people would come from all over the
world to come ask him and he's people
saw him as you know very very big one of
the greatest right the greatest Scholars
and they would come ask 30 questions
more than half of the questions he would
say I don't know and they would get
upset and they would go back and they'd
say what did Imam Ahmed say
and they would say Imam attic said I
don't know and he would tell them tell
them Imam Malik doesn't know right and
so we have to also understand our place
we don't need to feel like we just have
to reply to everything if we truly don't
know something we don't answer because
we are responsible for the information
that we convey so yes these Christians
they will come and they have bad
information and they have a lot of them
some have bad intentions some have good
intentions but for the ones who do have
good intentions we can't have wrong
information to tell them because we
don't want to be responsible for
misguiding them even further making them
not want to come to Islam absolutely yep
um did Jesus ascend to heaven like
because I've read that Islam and Islam
they believe Jesus ascended to heaven in
the flesh in his body the soul the body
stays here the body let's go over that
one so we do believe in the Ascension
that Jesus will he ascended he'll come
back but now is between the body and the
soul and he said just uh just the soul
of the body State yeah
um yeah which is not a position that any
of this
now they believe Jesus was buried
somewhere and yeah yeah he I mean this
I from what I asked afterwards this is
mosque right but this is just a man who
I don't I don't I think he was just
unprepared he doesn't know stuff maybe
he heard wrong things this is this is
what they do right yeah yeah they
attacked the unprepared they go after
those that you know that seemingly don't
know much like more than just the basic
base Basics and and they capitalize on
it so what's the proper response so
they're proper responses I mean is that
you know Jesus peace be upon him he was
raised body and soul and also besides
that um
right he was not killed he was not
crucified it was made to appear so and
then in Surin he sat when Allah talks
about it he said we have raised him to
ourselves right and all of the scholars
are unanimous that when he was raised it
was right raised completely whole body
whole soul because when he returns he
will return Body and Soul not he won't
be his soul comes down into like a body
that's sitting here or into a baby's
body or something like that right that
the Islamic belief is that Jesus will
return as he was lifted up in the same
age in Damascus where you know where the
you know the leader of the Muslims will
be at that time and they won't go and go
and take on the Antichrist literally
clear that up yep like I saw one time in
this church a lady got like literally
got up out of a wheelchair and I was
like what the heck do you think that
stuff is real oh I do
you cannot prove to me okay you cannot
show me anywhere I can't where we took
the Bible and created the Quran so
you're saying that he just that Muhammad
just knew the Bible
he took how do you like to answer that
you you often hear people repeat this
also it's another thing that the Quran
was copied from the Bible they say it
was covered from the Torah too a lot
they use that a lot
and it's it's it has no standings you
know just because there's prophets that
that share names in both books
they automatically assume that it's been
copied you know but we know for a fact
that was illiterate
you know we know that
we and then this is this is accepted by
consensus this isn't just Muslims saying
this this is
an all-around consensus
so if he was illiterate if he couldn't
read or write how is he copying this
from a Bible which they didn't even have
in Arabic at that time around that time
there was one Professor who said it and
this is someone who
is a professor in the University he was
talking to a Muslim and he said oh yeah
I know Prophet Muhammad he admitted yeah
he was illiterate so he admitted this
but he said his cousin one of his
cousins his cousin Alpha yes he was the
smart one and he taught him now
he taught him all this stuff and there's
a problem still with that
and this is just a this is a logical
proof if somebody was to copy something
right if if the claim is that the Quran
copied from the Bible
why did it not copy everything the same
way the mistakes why didn't I copy the
yeah exactly the mistake so if I'm copy
people have a picture in their mind
check it out you're with uh your
colleague a friend you're sitting next
to another and you're over here looking
at his stuff he's taking a test and I'm
going to copy his test I'm going to do
his same answers if you get a c he gets
to see if he gets to see you get a c but
I get an A but you get an A
how's that work well and that's the
thing this is this is why that argument
when it's fully examined it falls on his
face and I mean fully examine not just
repeating things that you hear and leave
it at that just so you can feel like you
want some uh debate or well that's
that's the trick right if you say
something was it if you say something
enough
if you repeat a lie enough to believe it
exactly yes yes and that's why the
people who push this stuff ever I mean
ever since 9 11 right when you heard
these speeches whenever any the
president or anyone else would give
these speeches from these think tanks
and all this other stuff they would they
would estimate the average time the word
terrorism or uh you know I don't know
what
other bad words that you can't use they
would average say these words 70 times
per speech so you haven't said so many
times in the subconscious of the people
listening they're going to start making
what what's called association yes right
it's not like subliminal messaging like
magic and stuff but it's no it's
repetition within the human mind becomes
that's why they say practice makes
perfect well practice actually doesn't
make perfect practice makes permanent so
when something is done enough times you
have you get what's muscle memory our
muscle like our brain is also very
similar to that in that that's how we
memorize Quran we repeat the verses over
and over again until it's memorized and
so when people repeat these same
incorrect facts incorrect things about
Islam and about whatever it becomes so
second nature to them that they've
convinced themselves or that convinced
their followers that it's true let's
take a look at that what would you call
he was like uh would you say he's a
Christian scholar yeah I mean they we
consider them a you know a monotheistic
Christian scholar someone who had a deep
insight into the life of Jesus peace
people so he believed in Prophet
Muhammad somebody believed in him right
but then he's passed away shortly after
right after the prophet got the first
revelation from jabriel he died within
those so that kills that argument right
there exactly so how is it because
Revelation is coming during battles is
coming during you know incidents are
happening in Revelation but he's 23
years after that 23 years later and he's
passed away in the beginning so when you
look at it again another thing another
accusation falls on its face right and
there's also information that is given
that not just doesn't just doesn't get
the mistakes but it says information
that nowhere else in the world it's even
found right that's in the Quran that the
Bible doesn't talk about and the Quran
talks about it and we didn't find about
about it until the last hundred years I
always look at the the overall
if you look at the overall context and
you look at his life if you look at his
mission if you look at it like a
detective what if you put it put things
to the test look at his message and his
motive what what was his motive at the
end you know you see him what what is he
gaining from this persecution torture
what's he getting money what is he
getting what's the whole goal behind it
the goal is to convey the message that's
it he said if you put the moon in my
right the sun in my left I'm not going
to give it up give me they want him to
give him to all the women they want to
give him status they bribe them with all
of the luxuries of this world they said
we've never had a king type of figure
like the Romans the Persians do but
we'll make you the key figure Among Us
just stop calling to what you're calling
to I mean politicians 99.9 sell out sure
absolutely absolutely and you know when
the when the uh what do they call it new
term people use when the Matrix comes
whatever so when he gets uh tempted and
now that's it it's done they offer him
all this stuff and threaten him even yep
and he just kept going yeah and and the
thing is is with with this guy right
remember he's an expert in apologetics
right when it comes to Islam he's an
expert
um what they do is is they never hold
themselves to the same scrutiny that
they hold this lamb to yeah right they
never like they they will never ever
hold their the Bible like this guy's
like oh well you know this was copied
off of this and then we can we can prove
it that it's not but then whenever we
try to put their own scrutiny their own
tactics that they try to use against
Islam on them they'll never go for it
and not to disrespect any of our
Christian friends and neighbors just
bringing these things out for
educational purposes absolutely
especially to this individual here if
you look at if you really want to be
technical you being a former Christian
if you look at we talk about the chain
of narrations the authenticity of Islam
if you put the scrutiny towards the the
Bible many Christians don't know that
these are Anonymous books the majority
like the gospels the Matthew Mark Luke
and John we don't know is that true
Bible scholar tell us so we're just
telling you this is what the academics
who went to Seminary School study
textual criticism they're telling us now
these are academics not the laymen
they're saying this is mysterious cue
what is it yeah yeah well The Cue that's
something that's a mixture between you
know Mark and Luke but you know no I
mean even amongst Conservative Christian
Scholars today it's now becoming a
consensus right which is where a main
body of Scholars right and these are not
all atheists because those like they
don't like it when they say bar durman
okay we'll not use bar Derman we'll use
other Christian Scholars it has now
become a consensus amongst the majority
of Christian Scholars that the four
gospels are completely Anonymous what
are not eyewitnesses for people hearing
this for the first time
it's like how much simpler can you make
it it's like you're reading a book and
then you look for the author and you
don't know who the author is
that's it that's as simple as you can
get
you don't know who wrote you don't know
where it come from you don't know if
they're what they're saying is actually
true Did they really witness these
things so we're actually debating things
and we're entertaining many of these
verses you know and we can still prove
the monotheism we can still prove more
than people can prove Trinity we can
still prove there's still remnants of
the truth there we respect and we don't
disrespect but we don't know who the
books are you can't if you want to call
someone to the court of law and bring
this witness you can you bring that
witness would not be accepted in any
Court in any society in the world
because this person has you know they've
you know there's things that have been
added things have been subtracted so any
person who has added or subtracted to
their testimony before they are not as a
reliable witness they will not be
brought on the stand or someone who's
completely unknown you can't bring
someone as an expert witness on a
certain matter who has no requisite
knowledge in that thing right
what's my identity what do you think
starting off a conversation with someone
like this who wants to go into because
sometimes we'll get into remembering the
Bible verses and that but making this as
a framework a foundation so they know
that you know that hey we can entertain
it I'll entertainment by the end of the
day we're going off evidence is actually
not even invisible in court of law so
and that's one thing that I've
alhamdulillah I learned in my dawa that
I've been doing last few years and I
really like and I want to say because
I've learned and benefit a lot from
Brother John Fontaine is you'll save a
lot of time by starting on this by
starting with showing look let's let's
first let you understand that what your
whole premise is based upon is is shaky
because the Christians say this term all
the time build your house on Solid
Ground not on shifting sand okay so your
house your eternity that you're building
your faith on okay because we respect
you we want you to come to Paradise with
us we don't want you to we don't want
people to go to the Hellfire we want to
be happy and to be pleased by our Lord
but brother if you see someone with a
house that their Foundation was done bad
are you just going to let them live in
that house no we have to tell you about
the foundation first let's not talk
about the roof and the other walls let's
talk about the foundation your book is
not you're basing all your beliefs on
things that most likely were not ever
said by these people these events most
likely did not happen the way that they
said they were right and even still as
you mentioned if we do start
entertaining it it still weighs heavier
on monoethism monotheism than it does on
trinitarianism even they have the Red
Letter Bible how to explain that so they
said the red letters is what's said by
Jesus Jesus who the rest yeah who are
the rest that's the question who are the
rest yeah have you heard of the Jesus
seminar I have not the Jesus seminar if
I remember correctly it was a seminar
that brought most of the modern day
academics and whatnot and they wanted to
see how many actually are the words of
Jesus and I think it was a very very
like they say small percent from all the
gospel oh wow
I was doing Voodoo when I was in Haiti
and I was studying Islam and I was
studying chakra balancing and crystals
and all these evil eyes I had an
encounter with Jesus Christ a
supernatural encounter when he came down
and filled me with his spirit I got
demons casted out in me no you don't
know neither one of us know this is an
important Point here
how do you know
how do you know this is well the things
he straight up admits that he's dealing
with Voodoo black magic and black magic
and then he says he said I was dealing
in evil eyes yeah what is dealing and
evil like I don't know self buying and
selling evil but but
um but you know he said that he's
dealing with with Voodoo and magic and
then he says he has his Encounter With
Jesus how do you know that that's not a
Gin playing with you yeah you know
you're literally admitting that you're
dealing with these things that you
shouldn't not be anywhere near yeah so
of course they're gonna come and
manipulate you you hear a lot you hear a
lot of this people I see Jesus in the
dream you know this king of me voices we
don't judge our Salvation or Hereafter
understanding on a dream
I mean even myself as I told in my story
I mean I had a dream right afterwards
but what did I do after that I went and
okay if this is true if I do have to
follow the prophet Muhammad for the rest
of my life there's going to be evidence
for it so I got a Quran and I started
reading it
and I couldn't stop crying for weeks
every time I opened it up because it it
resonates it makes sense worship the
Creator not the creation yeah that's the
thing these a dream can be of good dream
it could be uh from the devil it could
be ramblings from your mind it could be
anything but yeah it could be anything
but if that dream now kicks it off or
you go start to investigate you look at
you know ever since improved but just to
base it off that yeah you can't yeah and
that's what a lot of people do and and I
meet people all the time in my dowel
where they they all say we saw this
dream we saw Jesus and I'll even tell
them like I'll still man their argument
and say you know what you actually might
have seen a man okay I'm not gonna say
you didn't even see this dream I'm not
gonna say you're a liar you might have
even seen Jesus but I said what did he
tell you in the dream I like to ask okay
and they'll say oh well he he was just
standing there smiling and so I'll say
okay so did he tell you that he was God
no did he say worship me no so this
dream you were a Hindu and you saw Jesus
in a dream and you became a Christian
starting to worship him and he didn't
tell you to worship him he could have
been showing you hey it's me I'm a
prophet why didn't you start saying oh
I'm going to become a Muslim because
he's a prophet of Islam you see what a
lot of people do when they see these
things they might actually have dreams
but they make assumptions they do their
own what we call tattoo right they take
something that's ambiguous and then
they'll make an interpretation on it and
then they'll make all these kind of
decisions based on their own
interpretation when you know that it
could mean something completely
different right and that's why if you if
anyone does have dreams Muslims have
dreams whatever you you you know you
bring it to a scholar bring it to
someone else ask what this thing could
mean and at the end of the day don't
base your salvation on something like
this that is interpretive you always go
back to the evidence right you go back
to there is a criteria by which we can
know if something's from God right it
has to claim it's from God it has to not
have any mistakes and it can't have
anything added or subtracted to it and
it also has to have you know things that
are miraculous in nature right that you
would know that's from God the Bible
does not once claim that this book is
for me the Quran does
if you have any doubt that this is from
other than God then try to produce one
chapter like it and if you cannot and
you will not then fear the fire whose
fuels men and stones and the Quran is
completely preserved nothing has been
added or subtracted to it after it was
finalized at the end of the life of the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon Him wow we covered a lot we're
almost out of time here so just uh
wrapping up
he talks about the healing that's done
people come into different places as
you've seen Wheelchairs and whatnot
and you give a good example that you had
actually someone from your family yeah
someone from my family one of my uncles
yeah yeah he has a daughter with a
cerebral palsy and he many times him and
his wife had tried to take her to these
these Healing Centers and she was really
sick and he said they would never see
her
because they could not heal her right
because it was a real condition they did
a lot of it is staged it's staged yeah
and that's what he said he said I was
back there in the back room and he said
this is why he started he left
Christianity to become a like a a Jewish
Christian mix like Jews for Jesus
because he's like these Christians are
all faking it right that actually turned
him away from Christianity and you know
what's that deception that goes right
people use that Paul to justify that
exactly and that's wrong I mean it's
very wrong it's clear you cannot deceive
we cannot do that in Islam No No and it
said come with what's there what's clear
what's true we don't sugarcoat it we
don't candy coat it it is what it is
okay um
anything else that you uh
we missed out you think it's important
that might benefit some people a
misconception that he brought up and
what message would you have for others
like this who now who come with this it
seems it's obvious I mean he lets you
guys be the judge it came with some
malicious intent yeah but didn't really
want to learn he says he already is
trained it's obviously spreading lies
and dividing people so we have to clear
things up and yeah
so
you are going to get what you give if
someone's going to come with a certain
attitude then and and they don't want
guidance they don't want to really seek
the truth then they're not going to find
it right and so I'm all the people out
there who are like me whenever I was
seeking the truth the biggest advice I
can give is to keep an open mind and an
open heart and to stay sincere
and also to recognize and this is why
you know when my supervisor you know at
the dawa organization that I work for
pushed me to start the Muslim Cowboy is
I want people to recognize that Islam is
not something that's strange right it's
not some Eastern religion some brown
religion some Arab or whatever kind of
religion that's otherized and that's
what's been done so much it's been
authorized you don't see white converts
portrayed in these movies that portray
Islam bad they always have to portray
them as this this kind of look because
it has to be so authorized so this
distinct and different to where people
subconsciously think I can never be a
Muslim because
I'm not like them when in reality so
many of these people that are where I'm
from in the United States and other
countries right South America even in
Europe so many people are actually so
much closer to Islam or there may they
might even be Muslim because they only
believe there's only one God and they
want to do what God wants them to do
right and that's what Islam is to submit
your will to the Creator and to obey him
in what he tells you to which is to
follow the prophets and that includes
the final Prophet Muhammad right and so
I want people to recognize that Islam is
it it's you know the prophet Islam is
strange right and it you know meaning
that it goes against the status quo it
goes against you know people's desires
and you know corruption and all this
kind of stuff but in reality though when
it comes to the individual and accepting
it it's for everybody it's not something
that's for a specific group of people
we're not close Allah has made it our
creator has made it to where every
single person whether you're you know
Palestinian or you're Hispanic or you're
you know American Texan you know a
cowboy an Eskimo anywhere in the world
this disabled able-bodied doesn't matter
right blind deaf mute Islam is for every
single person so that we can be saved on
the day that is 50 000 years long the
day that is going to be so hard on those
people who rejected the gifts and the
signs that their lord sent him and so
I just ask people to look
if you have preachers or people who are
around you who are saying all these
things about Islam okay
you know I can't tell them not to say it
they have the freedom here in this
country to say it but I want you as a
person to sit down and sincerely say to
yourself is this really true do Muslims
actually believe this and if you want a
free copy of the Quran go to my website
you know the muslimcabway.com I give
away free qurans on my website and I'm
sure you can get some at the dean show
as well you know so get a free copy of
the Quran read it ask us you know
contact us you can email us
um and that answers emails to people
anyone to who is Ever anywhere in the
world
don't hesitate because you owe it to
yourself and you owe it to your creator
to have the relationship with him that
he wants you to have
beautiful if they take that opportunity
get the uh free copy or you said and
they can also have somebody is blind
someone is blind they need a English me
they need English translation of the
Quran in Braille in large print digital
copy so that they can read it with a
screen reader come to islambytouch.com
we are here we are here to support the
blind community in every way possible
whether it be getting materials whether
it be sharing The Message of Islam
whether it be educating Muslims on how
to interact and treat blind and disabled
people in a respectful and dignified way
that's what we do so come reach out we
got what you need thank you both thank
you so much
thank you and thank you guys for tuning
in visit us here at the dean Shawn to
get you a free copy of the crown go
ahead and find out what's the purpose of
life why you've been created while
you're here and open your mind and
hopefully you can take things to the
next level instead of staying where you
are we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you assalamualaikum
to my dear brothers and sisters in Islam
listen if you want an opportunity to
support dawah to get this area this is
the project for you to do that I'm
saying to you very clearly you know
whether it's a dollar or whether it's a
million dollars this is the project that
you need to support so we can have a
template you know for dawa and a
community and we need to ask Allah to
duplicate this year 10 times All Over
America
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedaneshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you